so you might know Steve Hamilton from
his 30 million dollar car collection
that he showcases on YouTube but you
might not know about his billion dollar
business that actually funds everything
that he started when he was just 18
years old and today he breaks down
exactly how he did it and the
unbelievable secrets of how to run a
billion dollar business on this episode
of smash the like button and subscribe
because we're closing in on 400 000
subscribers and it's one click away it
would mean the world to us and it's free
with that said let's get on with the
episode enjoy welcome back to the iced
coffee hour I am Steve Hamilton and I am
super pumped to be here today hold that
thought Steve before you go into that I
want to thank today's sponsor rocket
money formerly known as true bill are we
not addressing the fact we just changed
clothes uh we don't need to all right
because we're in a sponsorship bit and
listen for anyone who knows me knows
that I love saving money which is
exactly why something like rocket money
is absolutely perfect with rocket money
you could cancel unwanted subscriptions
lower your bills set up budgets monitor
your credit score and get a clear
picture of your finances all in one
place what they do is they basically
find recurring charges that keep showing
up in the same amount from the same
vendor and then they let you know in
their portal so that if you're no longer
interested in them you just click cancel
it's really easy and in addition to that
I've actually been using rocket money
for a while now and I absolutely love
how I can monitor my credit score and
also set up automatic savings on the
same very simple UI it's also incredibly
easy to sign up for and there's so many
other features that we can't go fully
into because we have Steve uh waiting
for us over here but anyway check it out
with the link in the description it
would help out our Channel tremendously
because we gotta get our conversions
please please I'm being honest so if you
guys want to try it out literally for
free check out rocketmoney.com ich or
use the link in the description down
below it would mean the world to us it's
a great app I seriously I've been using
them for years and uh I think you will
like them too the link is down below now
let's get back to the podcast thank you
so much for making it thank you give
headache we've both had a crazy trip
this last day we just came back from New
York minutes ago we set up and we're
here at like 10 pm at night so it's 1am
New York time and you told us that you
just traveled from Hawaii yeah I got
home from Hawaii yesterday
um was in Chicago for 20 hours and then
flew right back out here at 3 A.M
Chicago time to what is that 1am Vegas
time and then my body's still on 11 p.m
Hawaii time so I don't even understand
what's happening right now and what
brings you to Vegas uh we are here
shooting a show for uh Amazon Prime it's
called banging gears and so we're racing
JDM vehicles with European vehicles in
the same horsepower and trying to see
who has the best time trial along with
drag racing it's like racing around
basically the Las Vegas Motor Speedway
that place is Fast by the way there's a
isn't I mean you know this area right
and there's a military Air Force Base
right there so we're sitting there yeah
and all day long there are these crazy
jets flying all over us it was really
surreal to be there today did you
already do the races um so it's it's it
was a pretty messy uh we're the first
they're shooting the first two episodes
of like 14 and they got a lot of
organizational stuff that they got to
get together at this point so I would
say that in two days I've only been here
today but Tommy and the other crew were
there yesterday as well and two days
they may have got five minutes worth of
footage shot so tomorrow is the day that
they got a lot of makeup to do it's a
lot different than YouTube because on
YouTube it's like every moment is
content you just turn the camera on with
something like Amazon I'd imagine
there's so much that goes in behind the
scenes yeah and I can and I can do one
Spiel
um I can talk for 10 minutes and they
can cut that 27 times where this one's a
little it needs to be a little less
aggressive on the cuts and I think
there's 20 crew members there it's it's
kind of insane how many people are
needed to make that type of production
but yeah are you driving your cars are
those the three yeah we've got the gt3s
the 765lt and the 918 out here today and
what cars are you racing I'm racing
somehow I got uh they said they wanted
me to do the GT3 us which is the
cheapest of the three but also the
Workhorse on the track that thing does
not break no matter how hard you drive
it I love it so I'm looking at these
cars that you just parked out front of
the house they look so absolutely
incredible for me I guess I'm not very
like cultured when it comes to you know
luxury cars and everything so I'm
looking at this car I'm like okay a
couple hundred grand a pop something
like that yeah is that about in the Box
um the GT3 RS is about 250 the orange
one the McLaren 765lt those are going
for about 600 and then the gray the
Porsche 918 those are with the I have
the wysock package so it's about 2
million that's it
yes yes and and Natalia's driving it on
the track
um so and we're like literally racing
these things full speed so and there's
no insurance on the track and how much
does that worry you when you're driving
just like because here's the thing I was
driving a car just recently and uh there
was a semi in front of me and it ran
into a cardboard box and the cardboard
box Flew Over the semi and it hit my car
and it did a little bit of scuff like
does that scare you something like that
could happen way less than it should
like I I have a a weird lack of fear
about it
um so like at the Hamilton Collection
we're all about sharing our cars with
the community so it's not uncommon for
me to have eight ten friends over
um we've had followers come over and and
drive all the cars at dinner we did a
homecoming thing where I let 16 students
take all my hyper cars actually to
homecoming un chaperoned so I just have
an irrational lack of fear about it and
I should but I don't know and then the
Cena wrecked too like you probably don't
know about it particularly but I I had a
1.2 million dollar car get T-boned about
two weeks ago three weeks ago and uh
that changed it for a few weeks and now
I'm now I'm back to the irrational lack
of fear how did it get wrecked and how
did it feel yes like how to make you
feel what was the initial gut reaction
uh uh we were we were with James
stradman and uh it wasn't him by the way
we had 10 cars getting ready to go out
to dinner we were celebrating and we got
out of my neighborhood 10 seconds out of
my neighborhood and I'm like the lead
car and uh the last car is the one that
got hit so I get a call and it's
um nobody that we we put on camera
um but he says uh I just got hit and I'm
like
you'd think that I would say are you
okay but but he was talking to me and he
sounded okay so my first gut reaction
was and I'm not a horrible human I swear
um my gut reaction was is it like is the
car okay
again he's talking to me he's like yeah
all right Steve I'm like dude's talking
to me clearly he's okay
um and then he goes no it's it's pretty
bad I'm like oh my god
um and so I made a u-turn and I get well
right after I make the U-turn I I call
my our videographer I'm like dude you
got to get rolling right like you gotta
roll this like I'm not saying this is a
great Vlog but we need to document this
and like people want to know what
happened
um so Aiden is our videographer and he
starts rolling right away and then when
we get there
um again Aiden was not the driver but we
get there and I I realized that Aiden
was the passenger and I'm like telling
him to like he got he just got hit at 40
miles an hour and I'm telling the poor
guy to video this and I'm like oh my
gosh Aiden I'm so sorry I didn't know
you were in the car but dude had the
camera ready and he was filming
um so Props to him but yeah so that uh
he just pulled right out into traffic
basically like I have the subdivision he
pulled out onto a busy street didn't see
the lady so it's his fault it was his
fault yeah and just a special thank you
to Country Financial Insurance which
camera am I looking at because I want to
just that one right there a special
thank you to Country Financial for
keeping me insured and not dropping me
as a result they have actually really
fantastic rates and I'm not just saying
this for them like fantastic coverage
they're still keeping me insured we're
being extra careful with the vehicles
are they covering it yeah they're rather
going to be mailing me a check in a week
or so how does it how does that work is
that a stated value this is all new for
me when I had to ensure the Ford GT it's
not a normal process like you would call
up guy killing me I don't want to ensure
they actually dropped the Tesla Roadster
they said it was uninsurable after a
year of insuring it that's really weird
Parts they insured 100 of my cars and
there's almost 30 of them in the fleet
and I have funky ones like the Countach
hysterosa I've had an old Porsche Safari
like there's nothing that they haven't
insured some of them took a week to get
back with rates but my insurance is
incredibly cheap I pay less than thirty
thousand dollars a year for all cars I
know I know but it's because you have so
many of them that like well you can't
drive
what is it yes uh mine all in is
probably
3 300 a year for just four four cars I
think a lot of it has to do with it a
lot of it does have to do with the area
and we're in a very conservative Town
that's very mine's miles mine is like oh
yeah I'll put a 200 miles a year in the
GT I'll put uh 300 on the Tesla like
that's you know I just get everything
down with really high deductibles by the
way all of mine are like Max deductibles
yeah uh what happened with the Senna
though was that just a stated value yeah
so right so they call it a they call it
a
cash value I think but I ended up they
were extremely reasonable like I ended
up getting those are going for about
1.25 million right now I got that plus
registration plus tax so I'm getting
about a 1.4 million dollar check from
them wow yes yeah and then is the plan
to do they take the car then yeah so
they take it I tried fiercely to get the
car back Houston Costa really wanted the
car so I was trying to negotiate
something for him and they wouldn't do
it they had to send it to Copart there's
actually an only law that prohibits
anything nine years or or less yeah if
it's wrecked yeah they can't give it or
sell it back to the person and you you
crashed your Bugatti right no um all
right all right yes
um I have a habit of scraping cars as I
pull in the driveway like I did your
your GT3 my gt3s pulling into your
driveway
um I scraped the crap out of that and
that's a low driveway too and you just
gotta think I'm gonna bear like any like
any semblance of an angle will not
scrape you just can't I like head on
yeah or just put the front lift on too
oh yeah which I did not do I just didn't
realize it was that and then it scraped
bad but yeah Bugatti was going the David
dobrik's driveway and his drive like
Beverly Hills is really hilly it's
called Beverly Hills right but I didn't
realize that so I like get in there and
it just
I'm like oh my gosh but did you see the
driveway going up and thought that like
you would think I could do it or you
just weren't thinking I think that I was
hitting it at an angle and that's what
she said but I was hitting it at an
angle and uh it wasn't a good enough
angle yeah and yeah a lesson learned I
just won't Park in the strap like it's
really steep I shouldn't have I should
have pulled it in what was your thought
when you first heard that crunch was it
like almost good content or like what
did I just do yeah whenever I mess up
and I mess up plenty
um I'm always like yeah you guys can
roll it yeah you can film it like it's
fine I'm human
um and so yeah it's both and then David
dobrik whips at his phone right away and
he's like oh my God I'm like all right
well if he's doing it it's going public
like and he did he was a good guy like
he checked with us to make sure it was
okay and I'm like of course and uh it's
almost like and you can't even really
see me in it and the guy that was my
passenger he's getting texts everybody
assumed it was him and like he's clearly
the passenger but he's the only guy you
can see so to other people that meant he
was driving so he took most of the Heat
and but like we were heading to Monterey
Days Later so it made that car super
like famous well-known because their Tic
Tac are Tic Tac blew up so it was I
think it was a good thing it raised our
awareness what damage did it do to the
car not bad it was far less than we
expected there was like a two foot long
scrape on the very under part of the car
but you know what Steve before you
question why we change clothes again we
got to tell you about something that we
do feel would actually help your
business quite a bit and that would be
our sponsor streamer Steve I know you've
been wanting to start a podcast just
like us but if you wanted to do so you
don't need to build out such an
expensive Studio like this Steve I know
you have a lot of questions right now
but just bite your tongue for a quick
second because stream yard is a live
streaming Studio platform that's great
for Content creators who want to create
high quality content on a budget now
Steve and anybody else watching I know
you in particular do a lot of content
creation on YouTube and you create
really high quality videos but with this
you'd be able to get high quality
content right from your browser and
stream it directly to all the social
media sites all in one place I think I
will download stream yard now
exclamation mark hold on Steve don't get
stream yard right now wait for the end
of the pitch man I'm sorry whether you
just want to start live streaming or
easily create new content stream yard
makes it simple to get professional and
Polished concrete every single time I
think you meant to say content not
concrete but regardless guys just check
out stream yard with the link Down Below
in the description it helps us out a ton
thank you so much stream yard and back
to the podcast we got to tell them okay
just sign up please it's crazy how
listen guys if you're on the fence about
signing up and you're not quite sure
about it I'll make you a deal actually
we will make you a deal comment down
below and let us know what it will take
to get you to sign up for stream yard
whether it's like you know what I Derek
Ram to eat 10 hard-boiled eggs and then
I'll do it and then uh guess what I'll
do it on the next podcast so uh if we
make that deal
just comment down below and include Jack
don't make this I could eat 10 bucks
we get to drive all these cars every day
and it feels it's like normalized now
like it's like oh well I gotta take the
7650t all right like it's just
normalized for us and you have people
that come into our headquarters and
they're like so thrilled they never see
the like they don't see a lot Ferrari
they don't see a 918 a P1 and like we
don't really we just forget how like
significant it can be to someone like
I'm getting letters about how it changed
people's lives it motivated them and
like you probably get the same all the
time and uh it's neat to see that and we
always have to remember that that it's
significant to people so
um we always want to make sure that
we're
I know I'm pivoting here but giving
people like it's so important to give
people access to these and you'd be
amazed at how many people have driven
that Bugatti probably probably 200
different people have driven that thing
um it's I'm a little bit insane so how
many miles how many how much are you
selling it for I'm hoping to get around
2.8 to 3 million dollars it's going up
for auction at Sotheby's Amelia Island
in Florida
um we determined that would probably be
the best way to to sell it off
um why Sotheby's not like bring a
trailer or like uh it's hard because we
were trying to go a dealer out and the
Dealer's like well I have to be honest
about this history and I'm like it's
always good to be honest the problem is
that on YouTube you see the one percent
of the time that I'm hooning that car
and like going crazy we're 99 of the
time like I'm just driving and cruising
in the car I mean I like to have fun
with it but
um the dealers that I've talked to like
they have a specific clientele that they
need to be very forthright and they got
to say yes this car was abused for but
really the car was meticulous I maintain
all my cars really well there's a lot of
influences out there that don't but I
mean maintain them really well and we
really do take care of them so that we
can go beast them for that one to five
percent and so the dealer can't really
tell that story according to them like
this clientele they need to disclose
everything at auction it's kind of at
other people's discretion so
um it's at their discretion to do the
diligence so we're not trying to hide
anything like I could have painted the
blue part black and nobody would have
ever known that it was my Bugatti but we
we want to fix up the blue and it's it's
just
just gives people their own opportunity
to make their own assumptions versus the
dealer steering them into it or uh bring
a trailer is bring a trailer is amazing
I love that set I'm addicted to it every
day I am just scrolling I've bought
several cars I've bid on 10 different
cars on there
um bring a trailer actually has really
high standards for you to be able to
listen I didn't even realize it
um I bought a Testarossa that had like
nothing was disclosed flood damage frame
damage when I got it and I'm like
I reported to them and they they like
forced the seller to take this thing
back
um and they banned that car from being
listed again so I that transaction alone
I'm like okay if I'm buying and bring a
trailer like your reputation is so
important yeah you're buying a pretty
good car and I listed a car my Porsche
Safari and like really thorough picky
process to get it on there
um so I'm I'm impressed and it built my
confidence about really buying anything
that's how I got the GT oh yeah bring it
down there yeah we got an M5 from there
and I actually got that same Porsche
Safari from there I think that's all
I've gotten from there okay yes that's
cool yeah how do you get an allocation
for the new Bugatti uh so what's the
process and what's the process like for
buying one yeah how does that work uh
so up until the last like three to five
years it act like Bugatti did not sell
out of anything like you you could call
a dealer and get an allocation for
something and and now there's a lot of
like Young Money young people that that
can become influencers and that can
afford these Bugattis like the hypercar
market is is Shifting drastically
um you have a lot more youth buying
hypers and then you have a lot more
people modifying and doing crazy things
to them without hurting the value
actually like it's amazing in the last
two years how you can go modify and do
stupid stuff and you're probably not
going to hurt the value where two years
ago like there goes 500 Grand if you do
an exhaust system on your Bugatti what
was the question again how do you get an
allocation
of buying a Bugatti so so back then easy
now
allocations are all politics and like I
don't like just candidly like their
politics and it's it's knowing someone
unfortunately the Bugatti one's kind of
a funky story so I offended Bugatti
directly they had their I was told by
their old um
I think he was their number one dude in
the USA but he's like your video where
you're pulling around Natalia on like a
snowboard and you pushing the car and
then you dynoing and doing all the stuff
he's like that offended our Factory
workers he's like we had a company-wide
meeting top down here at Bugatti for an
hour about your video and he's like at
the end of the day like we just went
like I had to explain to them like we
just want you to have fun in your car
like it's your car and I need to tell
them to that so I had at that time when
I'm having that call with him I had an
allocation with them well I had a I had
a like first spot on the waiting list
and they said I was sure to get that
allocation and then like and then I get
that call from him and then all of a
sudden like they're telling me I'm not
gonna get that allocation so I'm like
something's fishy here like are they are
they playing games because of my channel
and I still don't have an answer on that
but then I met a great dude that had a
customer cancel named Tim out of uh
at o'gara coach in Beverly Hills and
he's like I actually have an allocation
for an SS uh confirmed allocation uh
customer canceled so I bet Bugatti was
very happy to hear that I secured
another one that was guaranteed and a
lot of times you have to pay like
there's a whole Middle Market to that
thing where where people are like
marking up allocations it's it's really
obnoxious and like I kind of can't stand
it that that there's middle men that
that are like hey I know this allocation
I can't tell you who it is or where
you're going to get it I need 200 000 on
top and I'm like
I just that just I get it it's business
like I'm a businessman
um people are in in it to make money but
it just drives me crazy that that there
has to be a fee paid like that to get an
allocation but Tim was a great dude no
fee on top of it just had to wire him
six hundred thousand dollars right away
another 1.5 million dollars like I don't
know three months later
um that's the other thing oh so now so
that's how like I got an allocation for
my Pagani Utopia much lower production
count on that
um just having a really good that
there's another story behind that that
I'm not going to get into there was a
lot of drama there too there's a lot of
drama and politics behind a lot of this
and like I don't play that that's what
schmee was telling us of just how
intricate it is especially I think with
Ferrari is one of those companies where
you really have to get in there show
appreciation for the brand by certain
number of cars they won't tell you what
it is it's a black box but when you get
in then they'll give you these
allocations and I won't play that game
like I'll be honest like if there's a
problem with the Bugatti I've expressed
it like I've I've unfortunately thrown
Bugatti of Chicago under the bus because
there's been some issues with them
servicing my car
um I I've been public about what it is
like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna play
that game I'm gonna give honest input
always on our Channel and that will hurt
me in some cases and I'll modify my
Ferrari I'm not going to specify which
one but for I really doesn't like
especially when it's hyper level cars
I'm probably never going to be on that
list for Ferrari because they have such
a deep bench of people that and they're
only touching you know five percent of
people that it's that's never going to
happen Lamborghini yeah I've made it to
the lounge a few times but
um but
um right now good favor with Bugatti
Pagani Utopia was a challenging one to
get ramac Nevada not not difficult
because they're not sold out it depends
on on the exclusivity like how well
they're selling I'm trying to think what
else we have in order
um the new Lamborghini replacement
that's replacing the Aventador we saw
that at the lounge it's very very pretty
how many horsepower is that I can't say
I don't think my guess is eight hundred
it's got to be eight I was under and I
was under NDA so I didn't want to shoot
myself in the foot on that one could you
give us a hint of anything like um
without getting sued I can let me let me
think how
I would say that
it's it seems very different looking
like it's it's really it's it looks
really nice I'm really excited for it it
may or may not have a pretty significant
horsepower jump and uh it may or may not
um have solved the rough shifting
problem in the event tour that I really
hate yeah and that's why I sold my
Aventador
um but it may or may not I don't know
okay
so tell us a bit of your background how
you got started and everything yeah so
when I was 19 years old I
um basically had this Epiphany let's go
back even further I hate to interrupt
you but I think your story uh just being
younger not doing well in school but
yeah taking on like side businesses like
always being an entrepreneur you're
always hustling yes so yeah it came from
nothing like five different elementary
schools zero money
um Family on welfare back then food
stamps then it turned into the Link Card
in Illinois
um we had nothing like four kids were
sharing one like we had two bunk beds in
a bedroom and so you have to like you
just learn how to be frugal you learn
how to like fight for everything that
you get and uh so like early on I was I
had that entrepreneurial Spirit like I
set up a bike shop in sixth grade where
I was repairing local bikes
um I started working as a caddy at age
13 so I've actually been working since I
was 13 years old 15 plus hours a week
well it got a lot more as as I started
my business but then I worked at
McDonald's because it paid a little
better from 14 to 60 and then a local
grocery store
um for about two or three years in the
deli so I I worked like I had to
sacrifice Sports in high school to go
work because I wanted stuff like I
needed Nice Clothing I need a car
and so that I think just that that work
ethic or just like drive as a kid and
like I didn't want to repeat the
mistakes of my parents to be honest with
you like there's
there's a
I don't know I would say that I was the
most rebellious like
um and I've said it in my videos and I
don't want to beat a dead horse but like
I've never actually drank I've never had
a sip of alcohol because there was abuse
like growing up like my parents abused
alcohol and you see that and I'm like At
first I just I made a decision not to do
it because
um
it was like rebellious it's like I'm
gonna show them that I can't do this
like that like it's so frustrating that
I have to deal with this like I'm going
to show them that you can live life
without alcohol and then I I was fine
until 18 I didn't do it at 21 I didn't
do it at 25 and I'm like well if I made
it that far I'll just there's no need to
really ever drink
um same with work like
you know there's there's certain aspects
of my parents life that trickled into
their their work life that made it
really hard for them to to rise above
and uh and be better you know my parents
did work hard like they provided for us
and I appreciate them for doing that
um but ultimately they just they didn't
have this skill set or maybe the drive
to to get out of that rut
um so I bought some wheels for my car
um I had a 94 Z28 that I worked hard to
buy at the time bought some wheels for
that wanted bigger Wheels later don't
know why the don't know why I didn't
click earlier but when I started looking
for the 18s to replace the 16s that I
had bought looking on eBay I'm seeing
the price of them and I'm like huh I
wonder
that's where the Frugal part came in I'm
like I wonder if I can find these
cheaper like directly from the
manufacturer versus having to go to a
firestone or somewhere and then of
course you call the manufacturer and
they say no you like you have to buy
this through a dealer like you can't buy
this one so then I called the next day
and I'm like hey this is Steve from
Firestone what's my price on those Eagle
077 18 inch and like the vendor's like
well they're you know 88 on sale a wheel
right now like they didn't even check
like that was just fine that I said that
wow that that like that one thing with
that uh I was 19. okay so that that's
the only vendor like like a lot of
things happen I mean yeah I hate when
people say that that it's all about luck
it's it's more about timing and taking
advantage of it because everyone else
had that same opportunity that I did
that year
um they just didn't take advantage of it
right but that was the if I called any
other place they probably would have
shut me down or they would have said
okay what's your name like they would
have checked a list this one
manufacturer was just very like Podunk
um
didn't really care about that stuff so I
looked on eBay and I'm like huh 88 bucks
a wheel that's you know roughly 360
bucks a set these are selling for 550 a
set on eBay and this guy's selling them
I'm like well damn that's 200 bucks
profit and that that's that's a week or
two uh what was I working maybe 30 hours
a week at nine bucks an hour so yeah
that was like that was a week week it's
about a weeks of labor and I could make
that like just listing an auction
um so like I couldn't sleep that night I
knew it was going to be I just knew it
was going to be successful I'd never
felt that way before in my life and uh
so rolled up to the manufacturer and uh
the next day and started talking to them
I gave them a little business card that
I had from installing radios on the side
I didn't have it set up was it legal LLC
or anything it was just a side gig and
like again this was the right
manufacturer right time only guys that
would take a business card and start
selling me Product like everyone else
needs a resale tax ID they need like
they need a lot of information
um and not personal checks which I had I
was using personal checks they gave me
pricing they set me up question it
didn't question it so I got on eBay that
evening and I started listing product
that they had in stock right away I'm
like I'm selling seven eight sets the
first week so really I'm all of a sudden
making two thousand dollars or a
thousand call it you know a thousand
dollars my first week and like that that
changed my life and my perspective so
from then on it was all about listing as
much product and Brands as possible
under pricing the other people just to
undercut them a little bit get the
volume yeah we were listing a lot of
product that wasn't listed so it wasn't
just hey I'm gonna go find a guy like it
was I'm gonna list as much as humanly
possible because there was not there
were not many people on eBay selling
Wheels in 2003
um so a lot of it was undercutting
because my overhead was was nothing like
I was working out of my parents
apartment
um so that made it a little bit easier
to beat the guy that's in the shop uh
and you're storing all these wheels in
the apartment they would sit in the
foyer uh so most of it the other
beautiful thing about this is I would
get paid before I'd go buy the products
like I would list 20 sets of Wheels
I get paid the 550 I go pay the 360. I
instantly have that profit and then I
use it to ship as well so like we got
paid for everything ahead of time
um you know fast forward to now we have
30 million dollars worth of stock we
learned that along the way pretty
quickly I'll end that if you stock it in
quantity you get better deals you get
more margin of course there's more risk
right
um but yeah like I would go pick up
maybe 16 wheels and and they'd be
sitting in the foyer from the delivery
and then I'd have to prep them and strap
them together and go ship them and then
eventually there started being like
three months into it that's when I
figured out the bulk thing so I rented a
little office space like I don't know
block down the road and so that's where
we start so I'm this 19 year old kid
that has his own office I don't know
it's pretty it was pretty surreal it was
pretty cool how much were you making
back then I think in my first full year
so I started June of 03.
um I think that I probably I let's say
that even that seven months that I had
that I probably maybe made 50 to 60k so
almost almost 10 grand month and then
like uh the the full year after that it
might have been 150 200k pretty pretty
amazing
um you know when I was in college I was
like I want to make fifty thousand
dollars a year like I want to do a sales
I want to make 50 Grand like that was
the Pinnacle for me
um and
back then adjusted for inflation that's
probably closer to 80k maybe right now
90k so I don't want to artificially make
people think that that's like that's
like a logo like that was that was my
goal yeah and that was you made it and
like I did that while in college in
seven months when did you decide or did
you decide to drop out of college I did
not but I I only I was in a two-year
College called College of DuPage okay
and so I started this like
um what would have been after my I was
kind of just finishing my first year and
so it took me two more years to finish
it two years so three total years to
finish a two-year program but I wanted
to get that done and I've even like I've
even thought about going back and
getting a bachelor of Masters like I
actually signed up and enrolled at
DePaul then they closed down the campus
by me like right after I signed up and
then I would have had to try like but
then I'm like you know what do I need
this piece of paper like I I wanted that
because I felt inadequate or something
like I don't know what it was and I'm
like do I really need that at the end of
the day like am I gonna go waste I
should I only mean this as it relates to
me because I think that for many people
that it's important to go go to college
right and unfortunately when people make
hiring decisions I think that even
though someone may be qualified without
it just decided against it because I'm
like you know what I've done pretty well
for myself like I don't need I don't
need to go get that piece of paper and
and I've I've felt at peace with that
decision ever since then how did you
grow the business though do you ever
have any problems being taken seriously
being like 19 or 20 and like try to
figure it out on your own I would say
like I've I've always had so I've always
had the mindset like I've never been
content even like I don't feel much
different now than I did when I was 19.
um and part of that drive is like never
never being content and never feeling
like you've achieved Peak success and so
it's always about like cool I've done
this
and immediately get working on what else
can grow the business
um so
it's like it's having that attitude in
that drive so we started off with wheels
in O3
um by 08 we started doing tires we were
one of if not the first guy to offer
assemblies on eBay so like in 2008 you
could buy a full wheel and tire package
from us on eBay I went and figured like
everything I figured out myself I went
to a shop and figured out how to mount
and balance uh made sure that we were
profitable checked shipping on it and it
was good and then once that was okay I
went and hired a few people actually we
had my whole family work if we had my
brother Joel my brother Mike my sister
Jackie that was like our team and then
my cousin it was a five-man team
um super cool working with all your
siblings too
um and uh and then it was okay well
we've we've done eBay we've done room
and tire packages how can we build our
own brand like eBay there's no real
value in having an eBay store like
anybody can come in knock you out unless
the product you're selling is your own
um then there's uniqueness to it but we
went and launched Mr wheel deal with her
partner and a friend of mine that was
her own brand
um and then uh that was kind of a
website that didn't have a shopping cart
like you'd go there you'd get a quote
request and there'd be a lot of
interaction back and forth and then in
2013 I was approached by a guy named
Sean who had built like this awesome
brand called custom offsets and what
they did was they were just a femic
gallery you'd go there and you'd upload
a picture of your truck so it was a big
showcase for what vehicles and then what
modifications and what Wheels you put on
your vehicle and he had like 20 000
trucks uploaded a strong communal
Gathering and and he bought wheels and
tires from us and he's like how can I
monetize this like I have this engaged
audience I'm like well we have a
database we have a very healthy and
robust database we have customer service
mounting balancing vendor relationships
like we have all this stuff figured out
so we we worked with him to do some
logic around bundling package we helped
him with some of the developing and the
back end stuff their job was was
primarily to maintain the website and
then to Market it and then they got a
cut so that that and then same
arrangement with the company we we now
run called fitment Industries and custom
offsets and fitment industries are the
two biggest brands that we have same
kind of partnership that happened where
we were doing a lot of the stuff in the
background they were doing the marketing
and then some other Ventures launched
along the way including our own Brands
Anthem arcan anovia and and then we we
had all these funky things I had a
partner in Mr wheel deal I had them
doing this there were like six different
people involved
kind of competing against each other and
so in 2019 early in the year we merged
all the companies together created like
an ownership structure around it and it
added like like from December 31st 2018
to January 1st one day changed my value
by giving up some of the company and
merging my value increased dramatically
because now you have all this complex
goofy Partnerships and Arrangements all
bundled up into one common entity with
one set of books so that was one of the
best moves that I made and we've grown
we've grown 35 to 50 every single year
we've been in business besides last year
last year was a little challenging but
once we merged it was like 50 70
so it really helped for us all to be on
the kind of the same page how did you
decide to bring in all the cars and
start the Hamilton Collection so partner
Sean in 2018
I was stepping out of a massage place
all right legitimate that's not actually
it was yeah I know I heard that actually
there's a there's a story about that but
oh no no no no no
sorry come on all right so it's weird
how it all ties together because it was
all on the same night I'm like I'm with
my brother Mike and I'm like yeah I'm
like my wife and I go to these like 25
like foot feel spot or like Asian uh
spot and like I know they're legit
because there's usually like four people
in the same room together so you're like
there's not they're not going to give
you a happy ending with three other
people around you right so we found this
one that's still open uh Right By Us in
Winfield very reputable like nice nice
Town
um and I'm like oh they're still open so
we get in there and the first thing we
realize is okay well there's separate
rooms at this one but it's still called
Asian spa I think is what it was called
so we get in there and uh I step into
the room and the lady's like
I'm getting in my boxers and she's like
no no like you have to get naked I'm
like she's like holding up she's like
just can't see it somehow she knows in
my boxer so I'm like okay all right like
I've done naked massages before like all
right I was all covered up so I get in
the bed covered up and it was just a
very different kind of like
very different massage uh she was just
like throw some grazes happening but I'm
like all right like and then at the end
like 45 minutes later again nothing
nothing full physical had happened but
at the end she pulls the towel off of me
and she goes you she grabs she grabs and
she goes you want and this was a test of
of my faithfulness to my wife yeah
actually because you're in like a trans
right you're like you're like fully
asleep like at peace calm and then like
someone just grabs you and like it took
They're laughing I hear a lot it took
like it took everything I had but it
also took but it also was a quick and
I'm just like no no no no no no like
that that I was put to the test because
there's no emotional connection with
this lady like nobody could have ever
known but I'm like nah and I came home
and I told my wife about it yeah
um what was her reaction would she just
want to call this place up and like ring
him she's like you should report him I'm
like I'm not gonna end up in the
newspaper like
like what if they have like yes yes so
there are some other things along the
way you go back in hindsight and you're
like okay well like she was on top of me
like rubbing my shoulder but like
gyrating her hips by my head and I'm
like all right well some of the Asian
massages are weird where they do get on
top of you but she was a little like her
her privates were a little closer to my
head but like you don't think you don't
it doesn't add up until she pulls off
the tongue and grabs your junk
um now where the story ends is I want
I'm walking out of the spa I look at my
brother Mike and uh he looks he looked
like he was sleeping and I'm like
like like you know did they offer you
something he's like no I was sleeping
he's like wait they offered you
something runs back in
I'm like no no no Mike get out here and
then I get a call like right around that
timer I'm texting Sean and he's like uh
and and I only remember that it was that
day because of what happened yeah he's
like bro just get the event he sent me a
link for an Aventador at uh Dallas
Lamborghini and it's it's part of the
same group I got my Utopia from later
and that's how I forged that
relationship he's like just get it like
I had been kind of toying around with
the idea and he pushed me over the edge
to get my very first Supercar the
Lamborghini Aventador and uh fell in
love with that and then rapidly bought a
Porsche GT3 RS I think months later and
then I got my McLaren 720s and and then
I realized that and I mean this
sincerely but I realized how how much
people love these cars and like I I
genuinely love sharing my cars like I
told you about the irrational lack of
fear it's because the the joy that I get
from seeing other people having access
to these is so great that I just don't
worry I don't worry about the liability
and maybe I should but like just seeing
just seeing other people interact with
it getting access to them like I'm like
you know and I just really love cars I'm
like there's there's nothing stopping me
from growing this Fleet and so it was
just a systematic purchasing of more and
more cars well it seems like a bit of a
spur of the moment decision to go and
buy an Aventador all of my cars have
been like a Spur like 90 how much how
much were you making to justify that you
could just like all right you know what
I think that's a good decision I want to
do that at that time
um probably
I've always been actually pretty
conservative like like
even though I'm saying I bought an
Aventador like I I typically live well
below my I have a nice home I have nice
cars but I'm typically well below my
means
um and so I would say that I was
probably making one and a half to two
million bucks a year at that time okay
so definitely could afford right now
well I don't know well that's definitely
two million dollars yeah what was the
event there four hundred thousand uh it
was uh it was 312 000. oh yeah did you
finance it or did you just buy it oh
that one that one I find out so I do
like I have I have 28 vehicles I
probably Finance nine of them and then I
own I have a stack of you know almost 20
titles in my safe but like if I can get
if I can get money and and I'm sure
you've talked about this if I can get a
a note at two and a half to like four
percent I'm not gonna go spend two
million dollars of my money
um when money was that cheap yes um I'm
gonna go just put it somewhere else
that's gonna earn me eight plus percent
a year
are you comfortable to talk about your
income over time because I'm wildly
curious when I see these types of cars I
think so I think so
um so I'm definitely not cash poor but
like you look at guys that launch
software companies and
they uh
they may have a company that's not
profitable but they're but their company
is wildly valuable right so you have
people that have this billion dollar
company but they can't take dividends
because their company's not making money
um I think Elon Musk had that problem a
while ago where he's like yeah my
buddy's couch yeah yeah he's like well I
am worth all this money but like I can't
sell my stock like blah blah blah so I'm
not quite in that position but like a
lot of My Equity is tied up in the
company last year when when uh and by
last year I think I mean late 21 we had
a billion dollar valuation put on my
company
um and so I don't own the full company I
have six Partners but today I own 40 of
it so that's that's a pretty significant
amount of like net worth right um that's
we'll call it 350 to 400 million dollars
with the net worth however last year we
had our first year of basically we were
flat and growth and like PE firms that
knocks a lot of PE firms out of the
equation like they want high growth
companies and we had always been one so
we should have sold in 2021
um we didn't and um so
uh I don't know what the value looks
like today but it's probably half of
that
um and then my percentage time that so a
lot of my value is tied up in that
company but
um but and I don't just have like I have
a lot of properties and I sold a lot of
them because I knew that market was at
Peak I timed it perfectly I I buy when
it's very clearly cheap and I sell when
it's very clearly High I rarely play
kind of in between so I bought a lot of
my properties from like 09 to 13 and
then I sold most of them in the last two
years maybe the last year really so I've
timed it really well and so I have
income coming in from 20 plus properties
I have seven Pet Supplies Plus stores I
have an Arby's I have other Investments
elsewhere so north of 10 million dollars
a year now at this point so but but
that's that's probably less than maybe
that's less than you guys would have
assumed but I think it probably is less
than most it's about I'm so curious
let's start on the properties yeah what
did you buy what did you look for
um which ones did you sell I'm I'm
there's two reasons that I'm selling
them one was because the market is at
Peak value and then the other one is
because I'm trying to simplify my life
it's the amount of stuff I'm as I sell
stuff
and I still have to deal with it I'm
like gosh how did I handle this one when
I had exponentially more stuff to deal
with first thing I bought were single
family homes and they were always like
it was less about investing it was more
about Nostalgia like my grandma's house
came up for sale that that had not like
she had moved out of 30 years prior it
was the how she raised all of
all of her children is that by
coincidence it just you saw it online or
was it in the family they had to sell it
I'm like a big nostalgic guy so I'm like
I put like Zillow follow reports on all
the homes that I've owned like on the
Home Alone house uh 671 Lincoln Avenue
in Winnetka I'm like I'm gonna buy that
house when it becomes available and I'm
gonna turn it into a big attraction and
replicate what they did you're trying to
do that at The Brady Bunch house oh I
love it yeah I love it the neighbors
will hate me um but I'm gonna do it
um so it was it was two things it was
that like Nostalgia so I bought that and
then what did I do
when I bought it oh I think it uh my
sister I let my sister live in it for a
little while and then I started turning
it into an income property and then I
also started buying the buildings that
my business was out of and that that was
where a lot of the equity happens
um so I realized quickly that
single-family homes aren't really a
great in my opinion unless you're
dealing with really low income like at
that time called a six like a hundred
thousand dollar eighty to a hundred
thousand dollar house I just don't think
single family homes are near like you
only have one tenant they're not
generating the cap rate that I need
they're three to four percent out by me
um so quickly learned that apartment
buildings are the way to go like multi
multi-flats or if you get an industrial
that has six different condos or but I
was focused on apartment building so I
bought a bunch of apartment buildings
most of them were six to eight flats and
uh and so now you have you know six
different tenants paying so if one
person vacates you're still doing okay
um and then your cap rate's a lot higher
like you just make more from an
apartment building like a 600 000
apartment building is going to generate
me 50K plus out there where a 600 000
home was getting me like 30 35k that's
just the way that it is out there so
I I think I had
I don't know 70 80 tenants at one point
um across all the buildings and then was
uh our company grew so fast that you
know we were in 7 000 square feet 20 000
square feet 100 000 square feet did you
just keep the building and then rent out
the last one I would always so I would I
would list them at a stupid high price
and then I would try to lease them I
wanted to lease them because if I can
get someone to lease it then I could
sell it for even more
um money right if you have a long-term
lease tenant
um there's really good money that can be
had I think a lot of developers try to
do that they build new buildings they
will sell it yeah they want to get a guy
in it so they can do I I'm seeing so
many listed right now in Vegas where the
completion is over the next few months
but they have a tenant already signed in
locked in for 20 years and it's based on
that cap rate and then they're going to
sell that right away oh yeah they don't
want that a lot of them have offers it's
shocking even right now they're in
escrow and they'll get 50 higher than
what they would have sold that empty
like it's crazy
um it's crazy how that how that works so
we just happened to get the stupid High
offer where where there wouldn't be a
lease offer that would come in but
someone would be like I'd get an offer
within two weeks of my high selling
price I'm like all right well I'm just
going to sell so that would pretty much
happen every single time I sold my 7 000
square foot I sold my twenty thousand
um sold my hundred thousand one but most
of the stuff I had was residential um up
to the last few years and then we still
own the building that we're in a 330 000
square foot facility up in Wisconsin we
have a 200 000 square foot facility in
Batavia and then we have another office
building up there that's about 20 000
square feet so
um on those three as far as industrial
properties go
uh and then and then I had a bunch of
residential like I said and then just
just sold them all and most of it was to
do it just trying to simplify my life
like like I'm I'm ready to sell a
Porsche I I always want to be a part of
my company that that I helped build
obviously or that really that I started
I'm OG employee number one at the place
right I always want to be a part of it
but I also want to take some chips off
the table and and have that Comfort
level that where I have enough money in
the bank where I'm like okay well
I could step away today and be fine for
the rest of my life
um and I've banked away enough money at
that point where I can live I can live
comfortably now but I can live really
comfortably
um by
really helping continue to build this
company and get the value way back up
again what else do you want you
mentioned what you listed off quite a
few I started at the First with
properties what else was there
um I heard an Arby's in there seven
seven Pet Supplies Plus okay pets pet
supply stores yeah pet supplies there
was some there were some partners that
needed a financial arm and I was uh
um I can't get into too much detail on
that but like it ended up being where
where I was in the financial I was told
that I would need to put forth a certain
amount I ended up putting forth 4X the
amount after two years and I didn't
think that they were being managed quite
well so so I basically told them like
guys I can't put any money like you have
to start putting money forth like I
can't continue to bleed
um however if you guys give me 100
equity in all the stores
um I will assume all responsibilities
within the leases the loans that are
outstanding like I I will be the guy
that takes the fall for that and so I
gave them that out and they took the out
and uh at the end of the day I would
have never invested in in these stores
because I just didn't want the headache
if I could go back I just wouldn't have
put money forth but we have an awesome
person that oversees the Story's name
Kelly and she is like
work to actually get them all profitable
wow now I want to sell them and I have a
lot of interested parties again this is
about simplification of life like we've
gotten them into where there's real
value in the stores and so I just want
to sell them and and
I just want to have my wheel like I
literally want to have my Wheel company
and that's it and then over the next
year or two prop that up enough to to
sell some shares in that and just like I
feel kind of burned out at this point I
have other great ideas the team and I
are trying to make a vlogger on
launching business ideas and we all came
up with a bunch of ideas and like there
were some great ideas and and we were
going to launch a few of them build the
series wait six months to a year to
launch it but I'm like gosh I just I
just it's not that I don't have the
drive it's just that it's so much work
and I just I don't know I'm really kind
of I've worked you need the focus what I
didn't mention was I've worked 80 to 100
hour weeks and God bless my wife for for
like just being there for the kids
taking care of me but like for 20
something years that takes a toll on you
when you're working that much and I
think yeah I think I'm just ready to to
chill like it's it's too much I want to
talk about that yeah but I also want to
talk about the Arby's yeah how did the
Arby's come to be that's a same
situation same price really uh and the
Arby's is folded as of like two days ago
so now I'm like trying to negotiate out
of this lease yeah I didn't even run and
operate that one uh they operated that
fully is it just as a franchise yeah
it's a franchise
um so that one is gone and I'm just
dealing with getting out of the lease
right now on that
so there's a 15-year Lease sign there's
13 years left in it it's going to be fun
do you like the food Arby's house I do
like Arby's it's not somewhere I go
often but you know every once in a while
I'll get myself the roast beef with some
Arby sauce and some curly fries it's not
what you think of when you think of fast
food very few people think Arby's I
think that's the problem is you just
don't think about it right you don't
Market they used to they used to Market
a lot I used to see the commercials all
the time I don't see them anymore yeah
you know that does a really good job of
marketing who's that Lexar actually oh
my God they actually do a really good
job because they you know they tell me
to talk about them and then I sit here
and I talk about them Alexa is actually
fantastic they've sent us quite a few
memory cards and I gotta say they are
good they're very I don't I don't get
anything from saying it but they're
they're pretty good well if you're legit
don't get anything then then good for
you they send it they send us uh memory
cards and uh hard drives hard drives so
what I'm saying is ship them even more
yeah
hard drives yes also send to the
Hamilton Collection Naperville Illinois
uh got it
uh yeah I'm sure we could we could
record yeah I'm just kidding yeah what
are some of the business ideas that
you're thinking now and you got me
wondering on that
gosh I I feel like I feel like
there's three
and Tommy and Natalia I know you're in
the other room listening but sorry to to
throw you guys under the bus but I told
them all to come up with three ideas
each so we had 12 ideas and
correct me from wrong guys but
you'll have to yell
um but I think my three ideas were voted
the top out of all 12. we did an
independent vote in the text and I was
hoping these guys well you know Tommy
had Tommy had a pretty good idea they
all had good ideas they just weren't
good enough to rise to the top all right
and uh so
I still May pursue them because they
were my ideas
they still could happen right like if if
hits the fans at work which I
really don't think it will like I think
that like you look at companies that are
failing right now our competitor car ID
they had a 250 million dollar valuation
and now their stock is trading under a
dollar
and like they've had negative profit for
like I'm waiting for them to fall off so
like that that should help our business
if they inevitably fold but
you never know what happens and I want
to keep these in my back pocket but I'm
I'm thinking of through all three of
them are like gosh like I can't I can't
like one of them is a kids
car toy like a Power Wheels like I can
sell that but but you but it's all about
it's all about creating some kind of app
and differentiating like you can take an
existing one do a clever spin like
um be real I don't know if you've heard
it be real that's that's what yeah be
real just took something very simple
um and then uh and then liquid like
liquid death is brilliant they canned
water but they made it look like it's
beer so like that that's that's their
pitch is that it's okay great like I
think they're around a year and they had
a billion dollar like something stupid
crazy so so you can you can take a
product and and create something totally
new that's never been done you can take
something that already exists and tweak
it which I think is easier to do create
that app or you can create some kind of
service I think service is the most
difficult because you usually have to be
kind of on the floor there dealing with
customers that walk in so I think app is
probably the fastest like something
software related is the fastest way to
get rich but it's also a lot of money
required up front I think building a
product requires slightly less Capital
but still a lot that's more my
wheelhouse
um so one of them was software two of
them were product related what are the
most pivotal moments in your career the
choices that are decisions that you made
yeah that like completely change the
trajectory of your business yeah so it's
crazy how if several things didn't
happen along the way we would cease to
exist
um
one of them was Reliance on eBay like up
until 08 100 eBay sales and eBay started
to fall off quickly around 12 or 13
where where like their fee structure and
everything just didn't get profitable
the market was too hoard out and had I
not pivoted and built
um our own brand
we would have we would have been gone in
2012 or 13. Ebay is like one percent
less than of one percent of our sales
now where it was 100 when I started
right so
um shifting to that adding tires to the
mix that really differentiated us
because not a lot of people have good
websites built around bundling wheel and
tire packages that was that was huge and
clutch for us if we were wheel only I
don't think the profit would maybe the
profit would be strong enough I don't
know
um
I would say that
there were a few pivotal moments moments
during covid where it got really scary
for a month on sales where they tanked
and we had a huge structure built around
Staffing and we got really smart really
quick on getting lean but then it went
crazy when people got stimulus checks so
here we are like telling everybody our
reductions and everything blah blah blah
and so
the warehouse got out of control like
after a month it looked like it was
chaotic like orders were lost and and
like I went out in the warehouse for a
month and I was slinging tires and doing
stuff like I couldn't even walk in my
own Warehouse I'm like what happened
guys
um so like
I hate to say it but like if that wasn't
fixed like that could have crippled or
crushed us
um those are a few moments that that
come up but there's there's quite a bit
along the way I don't know that's
there's it's it's crazy how intricate
um and that's why so many businesses
fail it's crazy how many of those
moments happen and it's just having the
right skill set or the right like
gut that you need to be able to do that
like I work with people that take three
months to to make a decision and they
say one of the best skills about a
person that is a business owner is the
ability to to just shoot from the hip
and make an on the spot decision and
like a lot of these decisions that were
pivotal were just quick like this is
what I need to do right now I don't have
time to analyze this like this needs to
be done immediately and what was the
largest unexpected hurdle that you guys
had to to mount I guess
um
I mean I hate to say it again the
stimulus checks like that was just like
are you expected it just like comes up
it went like we went from having million
dollar sales days to a four million
dollar sales day so like you can't
sustain Forex growth for a straight
month like when you're staffed for so
your staff got a bunch of money you just
want to do five Wheels oh yeah with all
the PPP too uh yeah yeah that might have
been part of yeah everything trickled
down the PPP uh and then throughout you
know it just all sustained I forgot the
unemployment benefits too they were
getting 600 a week right 600 a week on
top of the other did your employees did
any of them quit or anything during this
time too or were you properly a lot of
people were scared to come into work and
um I I haven't also have an irrational
lack of fear about covet I respect
people's decision to wear masks I get
all that but I also just wasn't scared
about it like I and they needed someone
that that was that type of leader when
the warehouse fell apart like
we were a part of the reason we were
getting crippled out there was because
people were worried about working so I
just got out there I got in there at 5am
and I left at midnight I was working 100
hour weeks in the warehouse for that
whole month and and that's um
that yeah so like that helped keep
people start getting people building
confidence having them come in we didn't
really lose like we didn't lose many
people because
we didn't choose to we could have chose
to
lay off and terminate when we had that
very scary month but we we wrote it out
for a little bit
um and I'm kind of glad we did but like
a month after it went crazy we hired a
significant amount of people
um we had to hire and uh when I worked
in the warehouse for 100 hours weeks
that's when I realized that I actually
stepped away from the company for a year
and a half and so did all the other
owners and a lot of it was that month
that month like completely
killed me I'm like I cannot do this
again like we just need to hire a
c-suite like I I cannot be out in my
warehouse juggling this I need to hire
someone that's high paid there's a
there's a very big difference between
like a guy making six figures leading a
big organization that's a smart guy
right a guy making a hundred thousand
dollars is still a good very good
employee but there's a very very huge
difference between a hundred thousand
dollar and a 250 000 your employee like
I hate to say it but the 250 000 your
employee like
that I can step away my Chief Operating
Officer I have not had to go out in that
warehouse in what almost three years now
and I would actually have to go out
there every year and rescue them during
Peak just the the covid spike one was
the worst by far like it looked like we
were gonna fall apart
um and he has done a great job like you
just see the difference in that type of
person so we hired we hired that group
and all the owners stepped away for you
and a half but when 2022 was clearly
challenging and we were flat growth
we're like okay well owners are going to
step back in and and give give their all
um to try to turn the ship around and so
can you explain why 2022 was flat for
you yeah so it it killed the automotive
Ecom industry in general
um most of what I read on non-necessary
items necessary item as being like on
alternator if your alternator breaks
you're going to buy one anyway but like
ancillary items like Wheels tires are
oftentimes ancillary but oftentimes not
um the market was down 30 to 50 percent
actually this year on the wheel end
um it was it was closer to 30 we called
almost all of our suppliers and that was
on I'm like wow like
and I'll tell you why in a sec but
um so we finished I think down actually
seven or eight I said we're about flat
so
about flat sounds better than down seven
or eight because it's about flat right
um so we outpaced the industry but I
cannot stand shrinking like that's
like that that drives me crazy and
that's a big reason why I jumped back in
the mix but there were a lot of things
happening so right when the Ukraine war
happened that day
we saw sales go down 20 and it just kind
of sustained like that it was weird but
that also times with tax returns
um so Ukraine war kind of shattered
consumer confidence that spiked up oil
prices oil prices are very closely tied
to our truck sales and truck is our
biggest division
um supply chain issues our number one
vehicle that people modify are 2023 the
newest model it was weird because five
years ago the average vehicle that they
were by wheel for was six years old and
now it's the brand new brand new
vehicles people are throwing wheels on
them
um supply chain issues with the cars
that were 20 less new vehicles produced
so that's our biggest year right so that
that's a problem supply chain issues on
the wheel end aluminum prices
skyrocketed much higher than inflation
so when inflation was eight percent or
something wheels went up like and and uh
in the Trump era they slapped tariffs on
aluminum exports so like each year for
like three or four straight years Wheels
went up like 25 like so a set of 20s was
a thousand bucks is now 1800 bucks just
for Wheels crazy inflation so people now
can't afford wheel tires sell the same
thing so that all kind of happened
the stimulus check didn't hit in March
so we track every single month we track
year over year growth if people didn't
have stimulus checks in March of 2022
but they had them in 21 we're going to
see a drop and then people earned out
their taxes earlier that earned child uh
the child tax credit yeah was paid out
all throughout 21 so tax refunds were a
lot smaller there were a crazy amount of
headwinds that I've never there's like
three or four more than I'm forgetting
but it's just crazy it would also be the
fact that cars for the last two years
have really gone up in value and people
see their cars as an investment it's a
lot easier maybe to spend money on
something that that you believe is going
up in value and you're increasing its
value versus the car is declining and
you're spending money that you might not
get back in the car yeah that could that
could certainly affect or or they just
have less money that truck was 30 and
now it's 45 like I'm not gonna go buy
Wheels what's interesting to me is
from my understanding it sounds like
what you guys experienced to have that
flat year was just a bunch of external
factors all like pushing in all at once
yeah
how confident are you that because these
things were out of your control how
confident are you that in the future
these external factors are something
won't continue to push on you and
the business but what are you
gonna do internally to make sure that
you can basically continue on this path
even with all of those factors we um I
forgot to mention Rising interest rates
that's a big deal because a lot of
people use credit cards and finance
their purchases and that was a big deal
and that also affected inflation in
general affected people's pocketbooks
with with property and whatever else it
would be
um
we we got very
we got very close like when the owners
got back in we looked at the highest
level of expenses immediately
um we realized that there was a lot of
stuff we didn't need to spend money on
we also realized that we staffed for 50
growth and we were already overstaffed
by 50 so um wages were I I love my
c-suite don't get me wrong wages was
we're just not managed well so we're
like nearly 100 over staffed heading
into 2022 and we realized it when by by
almost the end of q1 that like okay guys
we're gonna probably be flat this year
um so we did a hiring freeze and then we
had to do a few rounds of layoffs we we
tried to keep as many people as humanly
possible but we were able to just
through attrition mostly through
attrition just and the great thing is
that there was such a strong there still
is such a strong hiring Market
that
um I didn't feel bad because these
people are leaving and they're finding
other jobs and and I hope that they're
happier so managing managing every
bucket of expenses down to a t looking
for any waste analyzing our pricing
structure like just getting in and
granular and every single facet of the
company and we actually despite being
down we increased our ebitda by almost
two million dollars this year even
though we started the first half of the
Year ridiculously high on expenses so
this year even if we're flat again
should be really strong for us because
we're just managing costs a lot better
it's it's just keeping a close eye we
have a daily
daily report that we look at on a lot of
different metrics like we're that we're
that finite with what we do and if
there's something that's that's a red
metric for two days someone's looking
into okay why was our gross margin X
percent like why is it down two percent
from what it is someone's looking into
and figuring out making sure there's not
something broken right away it's just
managing everything really well trying
to train people to like this is probably
the most important thing is training
your your leaders and above to think
like an owner it's do you really need
this like subscription like is this
really going to add value like if you
own this company would you go pay thirty
thousand dollars a year for the
subscription making them think like that
is making them make smarter choices and
it's making them manage their wages
better
um so it empowering them to be
entrepreneurial like is another big
segment of it as just a random could be
a stupid question but why not just go
public if if you're considering getting
we looked back route we looked at public
we looked at going to
um a private Equity Firm and just from
everything that we looked at it felt
like it would be easiest to just go the
PE firm route public require a
significant amount of Regulation I have
to be careful what I say what I do I
just don't want to have that level of
scrutiny and you have to keep
significantly we do keep really good
books but you have to keep like
2x what is required for you know any
other private company in my opinion the
P firm just seemed like the the best
strategic route to get us the cash that
we needed but so that that's where I I
think we'll lean at the time but that
Market's been decimated now too right
are you also price conscious in your
personal life as well it seems like yeah
just besides the cars
yeah you're naturally a Frugal person
I would say I would say like I would say
Frugal is the is the wrong word like in
some ways but it's it's
someone some people have looked at the
way I spend money and they're like it is
so complex like I don't understand how
you and and for me it's does what I'm
doing provide like enjoyment or value to
my life so if I'm if I'm in a plane
do I need to sit in first class like it
does it really matter and so like I flew
Southwest on the way here like I sat in
you know the middle of the of the plane
like it's more like it was con it was a
more convenient time and I just don't
really care where I sit there but like
on vacation like
am I going to go rent a big beautiful
home versus a maybe a tiny candle yeah I
will I will go splurge and do that and I
will go travel and and enjoy that it
because that adds a lot of value that we
travel with people all the time and that
that raises the
the bar for that that raises their
enjoyment experience
um so it's it's all just about how much
happiness it brings me and and so I'll
I'll be I'll look at grocery expenses
and I'll be like okay like we're not
gonna order this candy on Amazon like
it's three times the amount of what I
can go get it in the store sure I don't
know it's it's really funky but I try to
be very conscious and and not waste
money away but I'll also almost spare no
expense when it comes to enjoyment got
it
um what are your thoughts right now in
the car market like just the the car the
car market has been hit pretty hard yeah
uh if you're a like I'm amazed that
dealerships
haven't folded yet because our lawn is
getting very close well they did get
close and then I think their stock
bumped up a few days ago or something
who knows I don't know yeah but yeah
decimated like the the car value has
gone down you know 20 plus percent the
hypercar market has stayed pretty stable
if not it's actually gone up a little
bit
um I guess people in the top wealth
bracket even though they've lost
a lot of their income this year I think
it was 500 billion or maybe it was more
um they're still spending like
they're still spending stupid like the
Bugatti Mistral that just got released
five months ago sold out completely
um so they're they're spending behaviors
aren't really changing but the the
middle class and uh everyone below is
definitely watching their their
pocketbook not going and purchasing that
vehicle that's driving down price in uh
raising interest rates on vehicles is
making it a lot less attractive to go
buy them yeah so I think that the market
still isn't fully corrected though
because
I know what I bought everything at and
it's still a lot more than what it is on
a lot of cars so I think it's got
another 10 10 to maybe even 15 to 20 on
some of the supercars yeah
can we talk about your collection
specifically or ask me this question I
want to ask you too what's every car in
your collection if you can oh God
I'll go as fast as I can with what I got
yeah Bugatti Chiron Ferrari LaFerrari
Porsche 918 McLaren P1
the Senna is basically gone but they
didn't give me a check yet so I still
have to I still have to include that uh
Pagani Huayra and then I got a Ferrari
48 GTB I have a Ferrari Testarossa
Lamborghini Countach Lamborghini Urus
Ford GT Audi R8 uh Jeep Rubicon 392
resvani Nissan GTR what else Porsche GT3
RS McLaren 765lt I'm missing some of
them but we're getting close limos two
uh Cadillac 83 Cadillac Fleetwood limo
and an 89 Lincoln Town Car that I just
love driving see what surprises me about
that list is that it's lacking a um a
Mazda Miata
I think you could just probably if you
add one of those it will just complete
the collection right there we have a my
friend's daughter's name is Ella and she
she you are speaking her language she
loves it very nice very nice lovely car
a lot of superhero would be I think
pretty cool yeah yeah or I think a Tesla
Roadster version 1.0 would be very cool
yeah let me know when you're gonna sell
that thing I consider it
really that's such a neat right so
there's the right price I never drive
he'd rip you off man so he would he
would sell you a roadster yeah if you
went to him uh but I really wanted a uh
a signature 100 so this is the first 100
Teslas that they delivered and he said
well if you want a car to hold on to for
10 years I got this car here it's one of
26 ever made in yellow Ah that's it and
so when I saw the car I'm like I love it
and see it's one of one yellow with the
um oh gosh Alcantara interior oh nice
yeah so there you go one of one of that
so I figured wow yeah but I never drive
it I take it out every I'm the opposite
of you you just drive these cars you
don't care yeah every mile that ticks up
I just that's just anxiety man yeah or
or if anything were to happen to the car
that could get a scratch or like a you
know I scrape on the driveway
yeah it ruins it that's okay I'm
surprised you don't have just like a
normal daily driver if you're trying to
go to the you know I didn't think about
those when you're talking about your
memory or something we have a Tesla
Model X and then I have the Roadster in
order to the Cyber truck on order
um and then I have an Escalade I'm
trying to get the V series uh that thing
looks right up my alley and then the
Rubicon 392 I mentioned this one we keep
the dailies at my house so we keep all
the and the two limos are kept in my
house because like I'll I'll drive the
like I love them so much and my kids
like they're not embarrassed at all for
me to roll up an 83 Fleetwood limo to
pick them up from school like it's just
such a Vibe car like I feel like I'm I'm
in and we've kept them very original
like I feel like I'm in the 80s when I'm
dressing those things so I love it
um I'm all about Vibe uh what else do I
have at home I think that's that's
really a basically the Jeep the two
limos Urus and the Tesla yeah I was
speaking to the strad man a little bit
and he was going over the cost of his
Bugatti just like the ownership where
he's got to get an oil change he's got
to replace the brakes he's got to
replace the tires how expensive those
are yes what's the maintenance or like
the upkeep on your cars look like um we
just did a video on that so uh you guys
can check it out if you want to see it
but it was actually I was around 800 000
a year now that included some upgrades
that we did so I don't remember what
they were but like upgrades and
maintenance 800 Grand a year but what
that didn't include was depreciation if
you actually look at us putting 60 plus
thousand miles on the fleet now that
let's include some daily drivers that my
wife and I drive so it's not a totally
fair number but that might be 35 to 40
000 so we're still putting 20 to 25 000
miles on hypers and supercars um it was
like a million dollars worth of
depreciation so two million dollars a
year that it's costing me uh to do this
no this is a tax question but do you do
you own the cars in the corporation no I
I see a lot of Montana plates right when
I go out there and
um I don't I do personally own them but
I am I am using them heavily for
business like a lot of these miles are
put on for Content so
um we are
we are actually going to try to make
sure that we can utilize proper
depreciation for them we're working on
it now yeah yeah do you do all the
simple fixes in-house like an oil change
and like breaks and stuff like that or
do you send it all to the I used to turn
a wrench back in the day like I did
engine swaps I I did breaks like I just
don't have the desire to do that right
now I should hire a full-time mechanic
because it will be faster right um but
no we we take them to different shops in
the area so how much does the oil change
cost on a Pagani a Pagani I don't even
know what that one is do you drive it up
to just like a Jiffy Lube no no no that
one has to be shipped to Texas you're
for an oil I have to ship like all these
cars like the Bugatti goes into Chicago
that's not a far ship that's an hour
drive
um what else goes crazy far like when I
get the remark I'm gonna have to ship it
to California I don't even know where
Mac is it's it's an electric car it
broke all the top speed records I got I
was driving uh over 200 miles an hour on
Croatian streets and I got on national
news I'm like golfing with Tommy the
next day we posted the video I'm like
it's in Croatia like I wouldn't post
something like that in the US but like
in Croatia sure and then mate rematch
like literally the CEO of Bugatti and
the founder of ramazzi's messaging me on
Whatsapp he's like sending me all these
links he's like yeah you're all over the
news um wow he's like I need you to send
me your license and some other stuff I'm
like uh can I come back into the country
when the car is like gonna be almost
done because my remark will be done end
of this year he's like yeah yeah you'll
be fine I'll need to take you to the
police station I'm like uh I'm not going
I'm not going back to Croatia not going
back there oh my gosh yes so some have
to be shipped
um it's it's and Tommy manages all that
stuff and he does a fantastic job
um my whole team is great I want to make
sure I give them props because Natalia
Aiden Tommy could not ask for a better
team of people they they are really
loyal to the brand just really good
people all around I'm thankful to have
them and uh and they they help get
everything done around the organization
so that I can focus on growing my
business and doing other stuff yeah so
as simple as an oil change back to your
original question I don't know I don't
know my gut is
my gut is that's probably a three to
five thousand dollar job but I don't
remember that one specifically I know
the Bugatti
um like the the annual services like
around thirty thousand dollars and a lot
of that is the oil change because
there's like 16 different
um drip pan bolts and like it's yeah
they have to take the whole back apart
and it's a multi-day job
um but I don't know the Pagani I'm sorry
I should this is stupid why don't they
just make it easier to change the oil in
the car why do they gotta make it so
complicated couldn't it just be like one
thing off to the side and they know they
gotta change the oil and you would think
like making a lot of money from you yeah
that's the thing if they're doing their
hair exactly yeah
who knows it could be that it's just not
feasible or possible
um who knows at the end of the day I
don't know I know that Houston Costa
does a lot of his own stuff yeah he's a
pretty smart guy and I feel like that
irks manufactures when you post that but
perhaps to him for getting it done right
it's maybe a kind of a sad question but
what's the most what's the biggest
catastrophe that's happened with you and
your cars McLaren Senna
the center they got T-boned that was
just the worst thing that has ever other
than that it was all tiny stuff it's all
just cars breaking down on the track
where there was some small mini fires
that went out really quick that
everything else was less than 20 grand
and I say that like oh yeah it's nothing
it's just 20 grand but like that's a lot
of money but relative to the McLaren
Senna that's a 1.4 million dollar loss
like everything else we've been very
fortunate and people have respected the
cars really well you have any idea how
that's going to affect your monthly
payment on the insurance
um
they haven't raised my rates yet and
they haven't dropped me I've I've added
my I added my Escalade today that I
bought six months ago because I forgot
about it
um yeah so and they're like here's your
rate 472 bucks for six months on an
Escalade which to me is pretty easy yeah
it's it's really really fascinating but
I like my insurance company I I yeah do
they do just in your state or are they
like they're like Midwest they have a
decent presence out there I don't know
if they get out this far Country
Financial yeah
how do you balance the time between
everything and having a wife and also
kids there's the there's the old adage
like family first right but like really
it's really it's support the needs of
the business but make sure that make
sure that family is family is first in
the way that like if it if it comes down
to one or the other I'm always picking
family like I will stop doing what I'm
doing today whatever it may be if it's
affecting my family
um but
my wife knows my goal is to to step back
away and try to live a more peaceful
life so it's yeah I know she I know you
have to go back to the grind and work 80
hour weeks like I my life is work family
and then managing the social media
channel I get that those are the only
like I don't I rarely hang out with
friends
um and again a lot of that's because I'm
back at work like I when I was stepped
away for a year and a half I had a very
flexible and nice schedule
um it's it's just like
finding the best times to work so I work
with the kids are at school I work when
they're in bed and making sure I have
that time in the morning after school
with them and then weekends I try to
work very little or I'll work when
they're on their iPads it's working when
they when I don't need to be present for
them or when I can't be present for them
because they're gone
[Music]
um
that's how and then yeah and then
carving out you know six to eight hours
a week to shoot content and do fun stuff
um with THC with such a demanding
schedule is it worth it right now or do
you do it because you believe it will be
worth it at some point in the future yes
I don't want to Pat myself on the back
but like in in six weeks that I've been
I've been working really heavy for the
last six weeks and I probably will until
there's a sale event
the amount of stuff I've gotten
accomplished is seismic like I've I've
saved us four million dollars in six
weeks heading into next year
um and from vendors but we're also gonna
we also have strategized a bunch of
other plans to help move a lot more but
like the the amount in the like when
when you build a company from the start
you I've worn every hat I've I've worked
in the warehouse I've done email
customer service I know the way every
single thing works in the organization
and so I can I can communicate and act
more effectively in my opinion than 99.9
of our people in our organization
because I see every aspect of everything
like I walk in my warehouse and I'm like
aren't we aren't we double boxing Wheels
we used to do that like five years ago
like what
why are we shipping one wheel at a time
when you can bundle two boxes together
that saves damage and that's a lot
cheaper and apparently some something
just fell off or something got not
communicated and you know that ends up
being a couple hundred thousand dollar
savings I see things like that in the
last six weeks I've seen a significant
amount of that
um and some of it's not the way we used
to do it's it's I just went and visited
um another facility and I saw that
they're doing something a certain way
and then I have our team running
analysis oh that's going to save a half
million dollars okay well let's do that
um it's just I have a really good eye
for recognizing opportunity and taking
advantage of it and uh
yeah I think that only comes though from
you building it from the ground up and
doing everything yourself yeah and
knowing how it works yeah yeah it's it
yeah I agree I agree yeah right right
now I'm working on supply chain largely
it's stacking negotiating with vendors
it's creating marketing plans and like
so
um
my goal is to to visit every sector of
the company and do that same kind of
analysis and then and then just create a
checkpoint so like we have good team
members but but I can use my I can use
my lens to go in and make these changes
and then let them know what I did let
them run it and create metrics around it
to make sure that it's successful move
on to the next department so that's what
I'm gonna be doing over the next year
and then what would you do afterwards
let's just say uh you take some of those
chips off the table what do you envision
for yourself like eight years from now
when our kids are all in college I think
my wife and I will be traveling like
half of the year uh we just want to go
have a lot of fun traveling within the
next like if there's a sale event in two
years I think it's realistically
probably two to three years
um just getting back to how it was
mid-20 to to late early to early 2022
where I just had flexibility in my day I
always have to keep busy like when I
stepped away in uh June of
2020 I got bored immediately and I went
and got my pilot's license I wouldn't
get my my lien certification for
operating in the warehouse like I was
bored like I need stuff to do but like
I'd rather pick
fun stuff that like educates me
um then have to work 80 hours a week so
just a more Balanced Life doing
and I actually really like I less
enjoyed when I first started kind of
interjecting myself back into our Wheel
Company a year ago it was very high
level stuff it was like okay our wages
are X percent like how can we get that
down now it's like super tactical where
I'm working with Frontline employees
getting in the trenches and like I love
this part like the most like I love
getting in the transfers working with
team members that I worked with you know
eight years ago and uh and that's it's
actually really fun for me to be back in
the mix I love work
um but I need to know that there's an
end in sight so balance schedule
I think I'm spending good time with the
family right now because I'm I'm with
them a lot other than when I travel
um
yeah really just a better balance
schedule that's it yeah yeah so with the
level of intensity that you have for
work right now would you say that
overall it's like a really happy
relationship between you and work or
would you say that you're still doing it
mostly right now in order to ideally
like reap the rewards of two three years
in the future when the sell event
happens I think I would say if if if you
told me there's no way that I could sell
my company within the next five years I
would be less happy but I'm really
optimistic that we can we can get a
portion of it up and for sale in a few
years and again I always want to retain
part of it I just want to take some
chips off the table but because I know
that the end is not the end but because
I know that that's probably in the scope
of reality within two years I'm I'm
actually fine like I'll grab my laptop
and find new projects to do like I could
I could rest relax at night but I'm like
that's that's wasted time I could be I
could be growing adding more profit
doing something so I enjoy it so you
okay but what you just said was not
something out of enjoyment but was more
so out of like okay like I probably
should be doing something right now
because those are they're different you
know they are they are um
it's you I don't not enjoy it I don't
not enjoy it right it's just uh I always
have to be doing something I I've
thought of a way oh crap like I can I
can actually get started on that
um I've thought of something to do so
I'm just filling that time is it going
and driving a Supercar 180 miles an hour
that would be much more fun than that no
but it's something to to fill my time
that feels productive so there's there's
some value that I get out of it because
it feels really productive right so it
does bring happiness but a lot of it is
also out of necessity and a feeling like
you do need to do it because like you
said in two three years there is the
that is the light at the end of the
tunnel you're trying to get there yeah
and I would say it's pretty rare right
now in the last in the last few months
that I've felt really stressed about it
even when I'm working really long days
like I'm actually I'm I'm okay with it
again because I know I know there's a
goal
um so it's not really it's pretty okay
right now and what's the goal with the
Hamilton Collection uh to keep like to
really get the collection to a
it's it's funny that you interviewed Mr
Beast right I did yeah that was yeah I
think I watched it a few months you did
that pretty recently too right
um something like that okay three months
four months I watched that one I think
right when it came out cool um
I watched his video on how he cured a
thousand people from blindness yeah and
like that got me thinking I'm like I
would love to cross over like the car
follower Community caps it right like
four million like stradman is the most
successful and there's a reason he is
because he's a really good dude he's
really fun to watch but like there's
nobody there's a few guys like donut
media dimiro
4.6 okay there is a top though when then
you have other guys like Nathan from
unspeakable David dobrik you have beast
and like where they're just 10 million
like way way above that so there's kind
of sticks yeah yeah but it's not really
like the type of like show but there's a
lot of guys over over 10 that have
nothing to do with like there is there
seems to be a lower cap for car stuff
than there is other stuff so I want to
try to bridge that gap between how can I
go do fun stuff like that but but use my
collection in my cars and I don't know
what the answer is but I've challenged
my team with that it might mean doing
slightly less content but doing higher
quality content and I think that we do
our engagement's really really good like
I will say
I would say it would be better to have 4
million because the automotive audience
is so enthusiastic about the content
like can you see when James posts a
video yeah always a million views no
matter what he posts really good
engagement comment section is so
positive and everyone is supporting each
other and is encouraging him very true
and so like that audience for me is way
better than 10 million where it's like
they'll kind of tune in and out here and
there yeah so it's it's I think we're
kind of at a pivotal pivotal moment for
the good this is one of those moments
where I recognize that I don't think
we're anywhere near the end of the
content line but I think that we can
create even more fun engaging content
crossover but still use cars so I've
challenged them with that and uh and
it's it's doing that but continuing to
bring in higher quality Vehicles
continuing to to pitch the message of
sharing the cars with the community
bringing the cars to charity events to
drive people in there making sure that
people can access and drive the cars
um it's it's just continuing to really
Build That Brand I definitely think that
there's a way that you could do that
with more like spectacle type content
with cars I saw Mr Beast on something I
don't know what it was but he got like a
bunch of buses lined up and he got so
it's like jump over he did like 10
things in that video I'm like dude like
this that was pretty crazy I also I
remember I was with the strad man and he
was saying that he wanted to race like a
plane in a super fast car stuff like
that there's always ways that you could
figure it out it's just I feel like it
would be a little bit different than
like I guess I'm talking more about the
charitable aspect the problem with that
is you you dance that fine line of like
Beast got some Flack for it which I
think is silly because he he cured he
paid for thousands likes yeah but but
then you have cynical people that say
well he's doing an offer he's doing it
all just for Content but they're still
dude
a thousand people like people wouldn't
even know this is a surgery that that
needs attention if it weren't for the
video and he wouldn't be able to do that
if it were not for the videos so so
how can I help change people's lives
right now we donate all we we don't um
we donate all well we say we don't need
all profit security we actually donate
like almost all revenue to like top line
revenue
um so you know the channel makes twenty
plus thousand dollars a month but it
profits much less than that but we're
still donating 20 plus thousand dollars
a month right now I wanna maybe it's not
just donating that but using that for
stuff like what he did using that to
find that doctor to find someone where I
can help make a wish would be fantastic
like kids who just want to be in a
Porsche 918 and experience that the
problem is that it's how you you have to
maintain viewers so the channel stays
relevant yeah and so you can continue to
grow it and earn more income so that I
can help more and more people
um so I I have a lot to figure out but I
think we have the right personalities
and and collection and like I think
we'll get there and I
I have them on like we talk with a lot
of influencers and it's like it's Fly by
Night it's like I don't know what I'm
gonna do tomorrow but I'm going to
figure it out and I have them on like
metrics I still keep it fun like we have
a very laid back loose environment where
actually our personalities are even more
nuts in person than what people see on
YouTube where it's usually the opposite
usually people amp up for YouTube we
have to like tone it down a little bit
um but like we keep a strict metric we
have our everything already filmed a
month ahead of time you I think you said
you don't you do similar or no that was
me that I actually asked but you may you
may yeah I'm always usually a few days
to a week in advance the podcast could
be anywhere from one to eight weeks in
advance gotcha yeah shimmy was talking
about how he plans things like months
ahead of time and we don't go that far
but we try to get a month with other
stuff in the pipeline pick days it was
Doug too Doug takes a three months off
in the summer nice uh and he has three
months of content done yeah in the
pipeline they're all scheduled too smart
which is so cool so it just
automatically post without him even
having that far ahead but we also rank
the content and if it's going to be we
call three that's our lower performer I
have them look at a and maybe you do
similar but I look at our total
followers it's not just how many people
view the video it's how many it is
relative to your follower account right
because you someone could get a 20 000
view video and have 20 000 Subs that's a
really good performing video that's a
hundred percent of your your sub count
um so we try to make sure that at least
a third of our sub count watches a video
and if it's not going to be that it's
not worth filming but we want to make
sure that two-thirds of the sub count so
right now we're at about 400 000 so I
need I need two what is two thirds of
that 66 times 4 2 65 okay people need to
basically watch that video or it's not
really worthwhile
um so yeah we bringing metrics doing
that and you'd be surprised how
effective it is bringing my business
aspect into the YouTube channel as well
yeah for automotive I think that's
absolutely doable and I hear that the
automotive crowd I mean there's probably
significant overlap with what you do
it's probably the same demographic or
very similar but when I talk to people
that that make most of the money from
Brand endorsements uh they mention how
there's a premium on viewership that is
looking at Automotive content those
people are typically willing to spend
more it's a different income bracket so
they can get two to three x
um what a channel that doesn't do
Automotive interesting does I didn't I
didn't know that it is a pretty targeted
audience so it's not only just like what
it is but it's also like I know this guy
who does like ride share type videos and
he can get like crazy brand deals
because you know even if his his view
count is like 10 20 000 views video it's
like you know exactly who you're
targeting to and yeah yeah very very uh
specialized audience and and the awesome
side effect of this channel is like
fitment Industries and custom offsets or
other companies like it's hard to get
our foot in the door with big
influencers like we're like hey you know
how you get the message in Instagram
like I've got this business like I'm I'd
like to test out this this metric thing
like nobody wants to hear that nobody
wants to hear from a business but when
I'm like hey I'm Steve from the Hamilton
Collection like we're not for profit
like you want to come drive a Supercar
or hyper car sometime like get my foot
in the door with these with these people
and then uh and then you know they
realize that hey we're a pretty okay
group of people and then I'm like hey
you know if you guys want to make some
money and do some pitches for custom
offsets fitment Industries
um like honestly James strand I'm like
this would be perfect for your channel
um because he's doing he's doing other
things right now that that clearly do
well but like wheel and tires is his his
Watcher base are probably more
interested in seeing that him
advertising showing them on his vehicle
like that's actually good content
um so I found this like network of we've
made all these awesome connections with
some really great influencers and now we
have all these guys pushing our product
for money
um but it's it's just pretty neat how
this has opened the door up for all that
and it's and it's overflowing into my
wheel business and helping me yeah I bet
that would be a huge opportunity for
influencer marketing for you because it
fits so perfectly you're in it all ready
you're a fellow Creator and you run the
business yeah in the same field and then
in the same field and demographic as so
I also push our business for free
obviously and I try to sneak something
in into every video and there's a
personal connection it won't drop off
like
there's always a drop off when people
start pitching an ad but we don't really
see that because it's just so seamless
and people know I'm the owner so they
know that I'm it's not as much an ad
more just me talking about like right
but I own what I do yeah I think it's a
fantastic opportunity
yeah is there anything else you want to
talk about that's all I got really
that's cool we would love to come visit
you like ideally I want to go and see
the whole collection and actually do
like a sit down there as well yeah that
would be uh that would be a fantastic
year well certainly welcome the
weather's warm in Chicago there's only a
few months of that but yeah you should
make it happen June June and Beyond yes
great deal thank you so much
it's late I'm sure with the time
difference and everything it's uh hard
on all of us I'm sure I'm just gonna
fall over at some point but that's okay
thanks for having me guys thanks so much
thank you so much for watching a
thousand dollars until next in the
description
what just happened with you about
talking at the same time